hey congrats congratulations everybody
for what sucking on the crank sucking on
the crank of Mattel
sucking on the crank of Mattel that's so
dumb dude
drunk
hello hello
[Music]
no valley of Plenty and Valley of Plenty
Anthony watches The Witcher for sure
what
it's bad the show's bad what's the thing
you were singing
it's the show it's the song in The
Witcher that's probably just a show
thing it's not in the it's not the show
a coin to your Witcher oh Valley of
Plenty o Valley of Plenty
dude okay The Witcher
is the nerdiest thing I've ever seen I
couldn't even believe
it's just crazy how nerdy [__] is yeah
I I can't believe it yeah like who what
is this what is going on but the fight
scenes are awesome but that's it there's
nothing ah shut up but you gotta give
props where props or do oh dude and the
show's terrible also a nerd I'm not a
nerd I don't like the show here's the
thing about fight sequences they're all
good all the time now so none of them
are really true that is dude if you have
enough money they're all good because
that's all they do is hire like experts
who are amazing at fighting that's not
really the technology allows
sure but like
whatever you know I'm just saying I
never under I never even understood
to themselves like who cares I know no I
I don't care either I get it but I'm
saying the the reason what I'm doing it
is saying that is because when I say The
Witcher is The Witcher is bad everyone
says yeah but the fight scenes are great
so I'm I'm preempting that so you're
just uh you're like oh no everyone says
this so I'll say that no no what I'm
saying is I don't want that to be the
thing that you say afterwards in the
comments are gonna be yeah but the fight
scenes are awesome so I'm saying the
fight scenes are good the show sucks
this way and the comments they don't say
oh but the fight scenes are awesome then
now you got nothing to say yeah okay
well okay
I
accept it thank you
bow down or cow Tao to
pieces of poop or nerds the worst
sentence I've ever heard don't bow down
or kowtow to pieces of poop or nerds or
nerds all right speaking of pieces of
poop yeah 20 they did a poll I don't
know how and I said this to me I didn't
look at it didn't send it to you
I posted it on Instagram and Booyah
triple time
um triple time
oh yeah triple time really but we got 3x
wow
um so
28 3x of dog honors do not pick up after
admittedly do not pick up after their
dog when they take a dumpy dump in
public that's pretty crazy 28 and that's
who admits like come on yeah at least
double that for people that don't I
don't think that that's a big deal
for sure definitely more than that yeah
but like to admit to it means you don't
even think it's bad like get I don't
think it's bad what are you talking
about I I I don't do that I don't leave
my dog poop around yeah but if somebody
does if it's not in a place like on a
sidewalk or something it doesn't bother
me sure if you're like d on a deep hike
yeah and it's off the trail no no or or
if it's like next to like like you know
how like on the sidewalk sometimes
there's like a square of dirt with a
tree in it if it's over there I don't
care oh dude see I don't it's just the
aesthetic it's like it's disrespectful
to the to the other people it is a
little disrespectful but here's the
thing the cost of not disrespecting
people is so minimal you just have a
poop yeah and pick it up and throw it
away yeah you're just a you're just a
lazy piece of crap yeah you're you're
exactly what you let your dog just do
exactly it doesn't really bother me that
much what just came out of your dog's
rear end that's you
rear end butt what just came out of your
dog's rear end butt is what you also are
congratulations
there we go
said Matt says Matt Dalia and not
crystallia
um we got uh uh patreon.com lifelong
luxury go to check out all the lifeline
luxury episodes there's a bunch up there
now we release at least two a month uh
so there you go that's on our patreon
our Lifeline patreon which is
patreon.com Lifeline luxury and uh we
all have to look into it I'll just say
that we often do more than two I think
we've done more than two a bunch of
months so far but
um and uh for the first month right we
did for the first one I think so we got
like how many are there up there now
seven or eight I don't know six six
there's six uh so anyway uh go check
them out now Lifeline luxury and they're
great and just go binge watch it uh I'm
gonna be in Irvine coming up Brea and uh
Charlotte North Carolina Knoxville
Tennessee Little Rock Arkansas Nashville
Calgary I got a bunch of dates coming up
crystalia.com I'll be in your city and
if I'm not in your city I'll be close
enough so come see me chrisley.com oh
wow
um and if you have a question click the
link in the description below or go to
watch lifeline.com or leave a message at
the hotline and uh we love is
213-973-8095
and we love follow-up videos too I gotta
say follow videos are great because uh
we like to catch up with you and see
what's been going on and how you've
implemented our devices you know what's
interesting speaking of it implementing
advices
just yesterday I saved two people's life
uh how did I do that on the one-on-one
advice sessions that you can book I
don't know for yourself if you say
people's lives at matelia.com and then
of course last but not least you got to
get that merch if you haven't gotten
every single item of the merch you don't
love us uh in fact you hate us if you
get all the merch you love us and we're
also and turn your best friends yeah you
get that merch at lifelinemerch.com
there you go and yeah hey every time the
word Irvine is said
yeah not every time but a lot the
hardest I've ever seen Chris laugh is
watching the Pablo Francisco what was
the name of that special uh shoot what
was that called
um I don't remember bits and bits and
pieces yeah that and and we watch it
with Mom and Dad and Mom and Dad were
just like
I remember the look on their faces they
were like what is wrong with our son
like he was laughing so hard they were
like something's wrong with this that
was the hardest ever left that is
special I think that Pablo Francisco
that special touched like a nerve on 20
something
people it was and younger too it was
just so so that it was really big that
special yeah huge it was like a uh
direct line to what we consciously or
even subconsciously thought was funny it
was really weird because it wasn't the
jokes it was just the way it was it was
great it was awesome he was so I mean he
is so weird as I don't even like
stand-up comedy as you know but
obviously I do like really good ones
really good specials in particular and
uh I remember so many different things
from that space yeah well I watched it
three times on Christmas so wow all good
um God I thought that was so funny dude
were you even doing stand up at that
time no
oh wow that's forever yeah
um so yeah so that's what's going on
over here I was in Vegas and lost five
G's and
pissed
are you really pissed or you don't care
right I mean it's fine why is there
popcorn on the table why is there
popcorn on the table
poisoned it oh I know it's coming go
ahead go ahead I want you guys yeah to
talk about the box office
oh okay okay well
um Barbie will bomb Barbie will bomb it
will bomb people are like oh eat crow
why are people singing Crow because I
said it was gonna bomb oh well first of
all it didn't bomb it will it will not
make its money back it will not make its
money back this story is not over yet
I've changed my mind I think it will I I
overestimated
the American public frankly and I
shouldn't have done that because I also
know better I never should have done
that it made more money than I thought
it would but I'm not surprised I am
telling you it will be besides the fact
that they'll sell toys from it and make
their money with the toys it's metallic
[__] it will massively be it will be
something that they were like it was not
lucrative just as a movie by itself let
me just say one thing about this okay
now the whole Narrative of wow I can't
believe Greta Gerwig snuck in all this
feminist stuff into this movie that is
this big corporate uh Mattel thing just
a big toy company trying to make more
money I can't believe she snuck in this
subversive feminist uh narrative stuff
that's what they wanted there it's just
it's corporate allyship it's the same
thing it that like when you go on
Twitter there's an ad for Uber and like
they're celebrating uh pride month or
whatever it is it's like these
corporations they don't care
about anything besides money yeah and if
they if if a certain kind of way of
making jokes or a certain kind of
narrative or or or or
uh soapbox is gonna make them money
they're gonna do it so like she didn't
sneak everybody she didn't sneak
anything in that was the plan from the
very beginning so like you're an idiot
if you watch that movie and you're like
oh Mattel got played by Greta Erwin like
no Greta girl is an employee for Mattel
yeah
and congratulations everybody who loved
it and flocked the theater
they you you sucked on the cranks of a
of a corporation that doesn't give a
[__] about you
all they give a [__] about is making
more money so hey congrats
congratulations everybody for what
sucking on the crank sucking on the
crank of Mattel
sucking on the crank of Mattel
I'm dude oh you did all weekend long was
stuck on the crane I mean all weekend
Mattel
I saw it Anthony got on his knees in
front of Mattel and sucked on its crank
okay so so and Anthony thought it was
better than he thought it you know what
dude Barbie Ryan Ryan Reynolds or
whatever the [__] his name is Ryan Ryan
gossing is great I'm sure the Margot
Robbie is great I'm sure the movie is
fine but don't kid yourselves no there
is no like big feminism angle Mattel
wants money okay and they would say
we'd love to wipe dog [__] on our faces
okay well at the office every day from
the CEO on down to the people making our
toys in China okay
okay yeah we all rub dog [__] in our
face from the CEO down to our employees
under Sweatshop conditions making toys
in China such a long press release
if they thought it would make him money
I'll check out this email we got from
the company
the newsletter China c-h-y-n-a
um I'm telling you man yeah I I'm sure
the movie's fine unto itself but come on
people
it's gonna bomb stop sucking on the
crank of Corporations all right you know
crank of Corporations
uh yeah yeah I don't need it about it
mission mission impossible had a huge
drop off that's a shame I love the
mission impossible I mean whatever you
know they're all the same I avoid Jeremy
renders for the record I haven't seen
any of the movies including Oppenheimer
no I've seen I'm saying the new movies
that we're all talking about yeah see
none of them it could all be the three
best movies of all time I haven't seen
yeah have you seen Mission Impossible
anus rapture no I'm looking forward to
that one though that's the next one
Mission Impossible anus rapture dude the
names of admission possible are terrible
it's weird it is weird it means nothing
exactly they don't they don't yeah they
don't think dead reckoning like what
dude so dumb they don't mean anything
yeah dead reckoning what does that mean
I actually don't know maybe I mean I
don't know if they did if they know what
that is it could be Mission Impossible
straight up chicken burgers I mean that
could dude that would that would be a
mission impossible straight up chicken
burger that'll be a Smash Hit and
nothing about chicken burgers well I
mean let's hope not you know
you know
wow that gun most [__] ass gun ever
that's James Bond
what is it oh it's a dork it's a dork uh
that's all James Bond no he's right it's
uh
chicken
the worst gun Handler of all time no way
dude it's so doped
you know you're really supposed to from
what I understand
you're supposed to hold a gun like this
Ricochet back into your face
but like up high and close like so you
can see where your where the aim is
going yeah no Am I Wrong not like I know
nothing but that's what I was told what
no you're supposed to you're supposed to
hold it right oh we're supposed to pull
the trigger you should do it with your
mouth you can't do it with your mouth
um yeah anyway what am I doing I don't
know anything about all right cool well
like And subscribe and you know what
leave a comment for the algorithm did
you see Barbie did you see
uh cochinheimer what did you say you
know I want to see I want to see I want
to see Mission Impossible uh
there you go yeah okay I think that's
probably the last one we're gonna talk
about any of them yeah it's over
moratorium on all of it bye just talking
about the cranks of Corporations by just
so we're clear though you're oh yeah go
ahead go ahead just don't work there
what you're you're gonna sit here and
say after a movie has not bombed it's
going to bomb that's that's did I say
that on air yeah
it will it it is it is they are playing
like it didn't like it's doing well it
is if it ended right now it's a massive
bomb
a massive bomb here's all I know the
budget was what they made on opening
weekend the budget for the movie was 145
million dollars it made 155 million
dollars massive but that's not including
the publicity and advertising budget
which was way bigger 100 million at
least way bigger than that during the
movie so now that being said the movie
has crazy momentum so I don't know if I
feel that way anymore yeah yeah it's
probably still gonna people are gonna go
see that people are gonna go see
Oppenheimer or Mission Impossible next
weekend it'll have a massive drop-off
nobody is going to go see Barbie the
second weekend yeah I mean again I don't
think I think you're wrong I I want you
to be right I might I I might have to
just I don't even know anymore I feel
very turned upside down by how how
terrible everyone is yeah I went at 11
A.M yesterday and the theater was full
it was he sent us a picture there were
zero people in the seats I mean that's
true send us a picture that was or I got
there a little bit oh God he was so
excited
hey June uh all right also the amount of
people like wearing pink and [__] I hate
it like my my fiance was like hey do you
want to wear pink to it and I was like
absolutely not oh my did you call off
the wedding pink did you call it the
wedding no no I entered so seriously no
no I would never do that not for that
dude it was pink you were you should
have wore pink if you wore pink and you
showed up and you saw him and you were
going to say dead reckoning and you saw
and you saw Anthony he was all in pink
you'd be like Anthony and he would he
would be like oh
oh my fiance said
I think it's gonna do well the second
weekend and then run away
um all right cool like Shuffle away like
he's like he doesn't want to look like
he's running but he runs so hard like
this
all right all right okay okay okay all
right let's see
hey Matt hey Chris hey hello uh first I
just wanted to shout out Lifeline luxury
I think he's up nice because every
episode so far has just been hilarious
awesome thank you that's good I love you
guys is Banter oh yeah and who doesn't
want more delay brother content there we
go
so I have a question for you guys today
I just recently turned 30 and whatever I
asked people or not they keep telling me
that my 30s are gonna be the best years
of my life could be so I know everyone's
different but I was wondering for you
guys how were your 30s uh were they as
good as everyone's telling you they were
great up until the last year are they
full of [__]
so thank you guys for taking my
questions I just want to tell you guys
that I appreciate you every week
um I just wanted to shout out Matt
Delia's 30 minute sessions also they are
great and yeah I love you guys awesome
I'm such a good guy I wasn't even gonna
mention it well because I'm good but
don't yeah and then but don't say you're
like don't be like I should get credit
for it I don't I don't I'm just saying
that's part of what you get I don't talk
about it I mean unless somebody else
right first uh in fact somebody called
in once on this show with
a similar thing to what he and I had
discussed in private and you didn't even
mention it Mom's a word you're saying
into a pond bye okay
um you can never find it again
um did she ask first of all I'm still in
my 30s so watch it second of all go
ahead I am not in my 30s anymore I'm 57.
um 30s were amazing uh but you know what
it's all what you make it dude it has
nothing to do with what age it is I
agree with that [__] I will say like the
last year in my 30s were crazy wild bad
but but it was also amazing because I
got I got that was when Calvin was born
so that was the best year of my life
really to be honest if I'm honest if I
if I have to be you know you're
repeating the fact that you're being
honest over and over again yep in
different ways yep which makes you think
it's dishonest but it's not though
because
um yeah the 30s were
I mean here's the thing breaking
lives up into decade chunks might make
sense but not like 20 to 29 30 to 39 the
best decade for me just in terms of the
way I like felt and the quality of my
life at the time to me was probably
ah
like my late 20s into my early 30s you
know like uh yeah zero to ten yeah yeah
zero to nine
um but yeah the 30s are generally I
think every
if you were to ask most people
definitely most people would say the 30s
were the best years and what would you
say yours were
late mid late 20s to early mid 30s yeah
yeah yeah that was pretty good huh yeah
yeah my but that's generally a big time
my best years I know I can tell are
going to be 110 to 120. um
um yeah all right well yeah that's good
next one great happy birthday the [__]
the whatever man it's me [__] Johnny
Bravo AKA Matt's best friend because my
hair I am currently picking up some
sundials for some of my friends
birthdays from Goodwill and I was
wondering how y'all felt about Goodwill
I you know I shopped there because I'm a
college student and I just like shopping
there it's cheap and stuff but I feel
like these guys they're making things
cheaper like Walla Walla I'm Not Gonna
Wanna I mean I'm not gonna financially
need to shop at Goodwill anymore but I
still like to go there it's just fun I
enjoy it how do y'all feel about people
shopping at thrift stores that don't
necessarily need to financially be
shopping at a thrift store should you be
saving this stuff at the store for less
fortunate people oh I'm stealing from
Portland that's a big argument going on
on the Internet is it right now that
people should be shopping unless they
financially need to so I'd like Cheerios
input that's a pretty that's a really
bad narrative though I didn't I'm
unaware of that uh going around on the
internet but like a lot of narratives
going on in the internet that's a really
bad one but what I will say is
it's not like Goodwills are like hurting
being able to find things to give away
for little very small amounts of money
it's not like you clear out the store
and there's no replenishing immediately
right every time I go to take close to
Goodwill there oh dude this is four and
the fourth time happened recently
they've said no no we have too much we
can't take it oh okay so it's like dude
that is a that is a non-argument yeah uh
issue but that being said absolutely
don't stop doing that it's like an it's
an aesthetic Choice as well as an
economic choice a Financial Choice
you're not just going there because it's
cheap a lot of people go to thrift
stores in general because they like the
vibe and the style and the aesthetic of
like old chest like not why are you
getting your friends sundials that's the
better question what what what is this a
thousand BC yeah like you're getting a
friend of Sundial what do you deal with
that's weird who are your friends
[__] Aristotle I gotta go back in
time and see my friends euripides
dude life rip cities
um yeah I don't know I I think getting
sundials is kind of weird make the song
If You're gonna give your friends Sun
dolls make them yeah and make that hell
yeah dude make your um immediate
Medieval Times you know but it cut the
hole out of a frisbee put it over your
[__] and then be like oh [__] what time
is it but you got to spin around so let
me just lay down for that what time is
it yeah check out what time it is oh
[__] check it out around the clock look
it's noon morning I'm gonna get arrested
absolutely get put in the clinic I'm
horny so insecure the most insecure
horny guy that there is
oh [__] there's a chick oh oh it's 6 p.m
wow
well now it's 6 p.m okay cool man it
might be new again soon thank you okay
hey guys I first just want to say thank
you for being men who talk about mental
health and emotional awareness thank you
it's a beautiful thing given a society
where men don't do that too much oh
interesting thank you with that being
said I am a marriage and family
therapist intern I work at a private
practice in a building filled with other
businesses that are not there care
related uh um my problem is that while
I'm in sessions hearing my clients
stories they're in their heartfelt
stories yeah
um the business next door will
repeatedly be slamming their door oh
that can be heard in session
it also shakes my door damn it's not
being done maliciously yeah um it's just
a little older
woman's Incorporated storage time
I need it to stop though
um I am a newer girl in the building so
I don't want to step on any toes but
interesting it does need to come to an
end so I'm curious as to how you guys go
about this what are your thoughts
start by going to the other businesses
and not like
some kind of tattletail but just like
inquire if they're having an issue with
it as well like so so it's one place
that's doing this yes okay
and inquire if any other businesses are
say like would maybe we can like [__]
though no no we would go to them we
wouldn't like report them no no I know
but it's like but what I was going to
say is if they have no interest in
changing their sound of their door uh
that the door makes when it closes you
can it's not that expensive to to offer
to buy them something that would lighten
that sound
like what
well I don't know what which what the
door is but there's a number of ways to
make a door stop slamming is it what you
put the cushion thing on the bot what is
it one door how the hell do I know
I mean like I heard exactly what you
heard what I'm just saying is it did she
said it was a public storage please is
that what you said absolutely not she
did not say that I made it up yep what'd
she say office building
okay I don't know I made that up okay
well it's interesting you aren't
listening that's cool I tried to uh I
tried to it doesn't count yeah exactly
um yeah I think that uh yeah that's good
that's really good aided just because it
was there Glutton
um
I guess I guess that's it yeah but but
because then you could but what I'm the
reason I say the first part is because
say there are three other businesses
that are like yeah that's kind of
disruptive
say pool resources it costs even less
it'll be worth it to you in the long run
say it's like 240 bucks which it won't
be right and three of you so that's 80
bucks a piece you know yeah right
or maybe the three maybe you get three
people maybe one person's like well I'm
not paying that and the other person be
like I'll split it with you there you go
but the other maybe the other person be
like well I would have done it if we all
three did it 80 bucks but now it's 120
I'm not doing it so it might be done
because it affects her the most she
could say okay fine I'll put up 160. yes
oh okay I'll put a 160 would you do
however whatever the rest is 80. 80.
that's correct
um that sucks though I I
I used to go there was this amazing
massage place near where I used to live
got stroked
and it was next to a like a restaurant
and depending upon the hour that you
would go oh no yeah dude it was it was
like I mean the whole point of a massage
yes and quiet yeah you know and they had
like a jangly door and the kitchen was
right up against like it sucked oh man
yeah hey got it holder I got an order
number 16. hey yeah got an order yeah
oh yeah we can order you turn around
yeah we got an order yeah yeah yeah
waiting for that
come on chicken's ready chicken's ready
chicken's ready
here we go hey we gotta pick up number
number 15. come on come on
uh ringing ring a tower okay
uh all right I got emails oh okay it's
okay
hey Chris hey Matt huge fans just wanted
to say be my brothers love you guys and
stuff oh Houston we found this podcast
I've been putting it on Non-Stop
um yeah where I needed some advices my
girlfriend is a heavy drinker
subconscious um I drink a lot as well
but it's gone to a point where she's
been getting black out almost every
night and it's causing problems in
regards to like when we want to do
things at night in bed
um I'm just curious how I can go about
this
and what to say to her I do drink as
well with her but just not as much
um so just let me know how I can go
about saying it to her without causing a
fight or making it a problem thank you
that's very hard dude I've been there
and that is not easy
um it depends on the person but if it's
just like since I have no specifics
about her I would say
try to make it or base it in your
feelings not in your like any kind of
scolding her behavior or anything right
so for example say
at the end of the night I would love it
if we could also be able to come home
and continue hanging out and be intimate
with each other uh
instead of just like crashing you know
like and I feel like you know our
relationship would be better for that or
it would be so much fun and we don't
really get to do that when we come home
totally wasted also say we
make it about both of you that's good
even if you believe which it's I have no
reason not to believe you that her she
has an actual problem to a degree
whatever you want to call it and make it
about both of you don't say you
it's just gonna get you into trouble
somebody's gonna feel accused they might
get defensive it's such a good way to
avoid things you know
um yeah or yeah or you can make things
remember a little bit easier if you when
she gets drunk
take her phone make an only fans account
and start posting you don't have to post
nudes but like sneaky like uh we'll see
you know pictures and then oh oh I see
him or you'll be like next when you wake
up you're like yo you got so drunk you
made a [__] whole Army fans and she'd
be like no you you use your nose look at
your phone right about oh my God I did
this yeah you got to stop drinking right
I mean that is actually a completely
terrible thing to do to someone well you
don't post nudes right
see the thing about that is that you
might end up she might end up believing
you and then she'd get really really way
too scared like you don't want to yeah
yeah but you want someone to think that
their problem is way bigger than it
really is
yeah
okay but that's not actually what's
happening or just you don't even have to
start only fans just be like you know
what you did last night
go ahead you you robbed the [__]
liquor store right yeah and then we took
the money and then you just like tossed
it out the side of the car here's the
problem with do you know what you did
last night I've actually unfortunately
dated long-term multiple alcoholics okay
oh
three of them oh
let me think three of them yeah oh yeah
and if they black out and and you tell
them what they did honestly they might
say that they believe that they did
those things but the chances are they
probably still won't believe you no
matter what oh it sucks
um because if they don't have the memory
of them doing it and it's out of
character for them when they're sober
they're gonna be like he's exaggerating
he's I understand why they would because
it's like that's not a thing I do it's
hard to get through to someone about how
they behave when they blacked out that's
all I'm saying so try to even avoid
specific things
you know um but yeah the only fans thing
would probably work but it might it'll
also be evil although a Quebec fairing
should be like did I make any money and
be like you know not yet oh I've been
meaning to I never had the courage to do
it yeah yeah I did make 80 bucks you
have to get oh [__] you made 80 bucks
it's backward I gotta get I gotta get uh
I got drunk like that more often yep you
know uh-huh
oh I drunk be getting drunk gives me
courage and now I got only fans I gotta
do that and I'm immediately you know
what I'm gonna start to be a porn star
right I'm gonna start smoking polls I'm
gonna start being a porn star you know
yep smoke a post is it is it just me or
is I mean this for real is it just me
but like my sense is that the term porn
star is now thrown around without
consideration a long time oh that's true
a long time yeah so it's like not
everyone does porn is a porn star right
no but that's like it's like it is
thrown around like that though yeah it's
like literally calling a guy who did a
few episodes of CSI and then also was on
uh Gilmore Girls and the TV he's a movie
star yeah yeah
yeah okay cool glad we've glad we
settled that yeah okay next one okay
amen Chris uh I am just calling because
I've got a buddy of mine that has been
dating a girl for a little over two
years now she lives in Miami he lives in
Minnesota we live in Minnesota he's been
senior for a little over two years now
and honestly she they're just they're
toxic together and he is so hot and cold
about the relationship and
um they've broken up once the near
breaking up multiple times and he always
comes to me after they they get together
for their weekend slings or whatever and
he's complaining about her and you know
I give him advice and then like you know
a couple days later I'll I'll bring her
up again
um and just bring up the situation and
be like oh yeah it's all good now yeah
um and so I guess I just want some
advice on like what you guys would do
um if you had a friend that was
constantly coming to you for advice
um oh God on a situation like this and
and then just would bounce back like a
couple days later that sucks and just
say everything's all good did you guys
love the show that's so annoying when
people do that hey I'd like some advice
and now that I just want you to hear you
talk because I'm never gonna [__]
take it dude no hey I gave you the
advice I got the same advice for you
break up with her dude you're dating a
chicken Miami you're in Minnesota anyway
of course it's toxic it's [__]
completely different if you're in
Minnesota you're digging two from Miami
it's gonna be toxic it's such a
different lifestyle what would you say
to your friend though you'd say that
yeah okay get out of here dude you're
not listening to me you [__] ask me
for advice you ask me for advice you
keep [__] asking me for advice and
then I'll give you this advice and then
you and then you you just come back and
you're like oh it's all good because
that [__] be banging say say basically
that but without the very very last part
and oh maybe if that's the case then
yeah sure but it doesn't
you're a [__] dude that's how I do it
relax you're being a [__] man you're
coming you're you're running between
your tail between your legs and she's
toxic you're toxic you need to be with
someone else find someone in your own
City find someone here in Minnesota yeah
okay but this is where we live man
you could also just say
you asked me for advice about this stuff
but you never take it so like I want to
know why you're even asking me in the
first place yep and on top of that do
you even realize that you don't ever
take my advice like do you understand
why I don't want to give it anymore it's
such a waste of my breath waste of my
energy I mean I'm giving my actual I'm
dedicating my mind to helping my friend
and you never do what you seek like you
never take the advice you're seeking so
like this is not good from yeah and stop
it's toxic dude and I feel like you're
the problem in your relationship I
definitely have that have had that
experience before with people and it is
truly one of the more frustrating things
among friends yep I know someone who
does that with me in my life right now
yeah yeah it's not you no I know that
it's not me because I never seek advice
from you but yeah she's always asking
she's always asking what do I do and
we're like do this and then she just
doesn't yeah and it's it's actually
honestly
the more I'm thinking about it the
weirder they just they just they just
want to uh Express
words you know but also it's like they
know there's a problem and it's like
before they have to act on it they think
they might act on it and then when it
comes time to act on it they don't and
they don't realize that every single
time it happens it's kind of about
self-awareness so really all you got to
do is make your friends self aware of it
so that in the future he can be
self-aware like you never take my advice
but you ask for it what are you doing
you know yeah ask him ask him if it's
gonna happen though the guy's just going
to not come to you for advice anymore
that's what you want thing I guess so
yeah I don't know if we can hear about
it I mean man the person that does it in
my life will talk for hours with this
[__] and it's just like geez yeah
yeah that's no good yeah and it's just
crazy and they don't listen and and and
Kristen and I are like
I don't know what to do with this person
do what do what I'm suggesting it's not
me it's it's mostly you know Christian
okay do the thing but yeah it's not up
to me I could just leave the room and be
like sucks talking balls huh sucks
donkey boss okay
well so you don't really have that
experience then do you I do it's not the
same thing I I can I have experienced it
and then I leave the room okay anyway
okay okay next one
hey Chris and Matt so this is uh I
recognize him this one's mainly for Matt
um
you were talking about how you made
he made Bing you say Bing Bong lost his
mind and he said that you
sold it for Mac 10. you're walking and
then Donald Trump stole it from you
actually what happened is walking too
slowly you stole it from me and my
brother because
we [__] two years ago I don't know
how it started just over the years being
brothers and just having inside jokes
and [__] and
and dumb nicknames at one point we just
were so annoying we just went blah blah
and we're like we can't be saying that
in public but we do because
it's just so easy
so we do that right okay you actually
probably were walking in L.A and heard
us call each other Bing Bong lost his
money one day showed up and said it's
the year of the bing bong and we were
both like what the [__] how does he uh
no you know how does he do the Bing Bong
how does he know about it worse everyone
asks that when they hear me do it
worst submission
and we were actually The Originators
okay all right I'll see you guys dude
please cut together for some time him
every time he goes Bing Bong it will be
so funny all it's stringed along bing
bong bing bong here's the thing
no to what he said yeah no and also we
don't know you also my brother has never
heard you say bing bong and also Mac 10
was rapping when you were two so there
you go and I was like nine and I heard
Mac 10 do it and I started stealing it
wait what did Mac 10 do
you decide uh west side west side
connecting
ping ping ping was that Mack 10 who did
it yeah
really do you think it was Dub C no I
think it might have been Ice Cube no no
definitely okay okay yeah
um so anyway I appreciate you trying to
take credit for a thing that you deserve
no credit for uh good good effort great
minds think alike honestly good effort
yeah but epic failure back 10 was
rapping when you were one years old so
no Epic failure okay on that submission
Epic
okay okay so excited for the epic
failure hey guys
um follow up here so I called in about
my friends that weren't inviting me to
things oh yeah
um I took your advice I pretty much just
said all that to them and they were like
that's shitty and we need more so
um I kind of just scaled back being
their friends and it's going to be like
acquaintances or that's all it's going
to be so appreciate you guys
also okay I've I've never had sex with a
guy even once okay
I have a follow-up question this one's a
little more hardcore but cool I don't
have a good relationship with my mom I
don't like her at all even wow she was
quite abusive when I was a kid oh no and
I left home when I was like 16 17. yeah
now my older siblings were kind of out
of the house my dad wasn't around a lot
so they don't know slash didn't see
Slash I've told them some of the crazy
[__] that happened damn
and I want to go back to visit my family
but she's always there and it's always a
problem because this whole family
revolves around this woman and yeah she
is so antagonistic like every time I'm
there it's oh hi how are you and then as
soon as the rest of the family's in the
room it's like hey you never call you
know you don't tell me you love me like
you want can you come and give me a hug
like come over here give me a hug my
whole family's just like what you don't
love your mother oh God we're not
Italian so I don't know I did that but
what do I do like do I haven't been back
to visit my family in quite a while
because I don't want to put up with it
like
I do I pretend to like her should I just
get over it I don't it's kind of hard
like help it's definitely best to well I
mean this is a problem you can't talk to
people like that you know you try to and
then they just they get offended and
then they hang up and then they yell or
they yell at you or they cuss you out
and it's like all right why did I even
bother but that's not your fight you
know it's theirs you gotta you gotta you
know you you you
God it's such a that's really hard task
I would say it look if it all depends on
how much you care about and want to see
the rest of your family yeah if if it's
the kind of thing where you really
really want to see them I would say
tolerate it as best you can it's like
you got to take the bad with the good
yeah but if if you're seeing your family
is kind of just more like a thing you
feel like you have to do and if it was
just your mom you would never do it but
you feel an obligation to the rest of
your family then I think it actually
might be worth
you know when someone says what's the
matter you don't love your mother you
just you can actually just say no no I
don't yeah she's treated me terribly my
whole life and I love all of you but
you're asking me and I'm answering no no
I love my Mom I just [__] because
she's my mom but she's always like
bothering the [__] out of me so I don't
want to [__] hug her what happens
what happens if you say that that's not
even the thing that bothered me the
thing that bothered me is uh you don't
tell me you love me that is like that is
all right I don't feel like you're
saying it because of how much you abused
me when I was younger yeah because I
don't love you my my if you don't love
her but my sense is that he doesn't he
just said he doesn't well he said he he
hate he hates being around her and [__]
and doesn't like her and like that you
could very well be look the bottom line
is people feel like they have to love
their parents it's not true as a parent
you have to love your children as a
child you don't have to love your parent
parents [__] up you know some parents
much worse than others and
I know people very very well some of
them that just had it took forever but
they finally come to terms with the fact
that they didn't love one or both of
their parents and that's heavy [__] but
it's your prerogative you're allowed to
love this person that you don't have to
be so conflicted and be like well why
don't I love her why not you know the
answer
you were abused in whatever way you're
talking about when you were young and it
[__] you up obviously made you resent
her you don't have to love her so maybe
when she asks in a way that is
confrontational tell her
it's like that'll be a crazy shitstorm
but like yeah you telling you to visit
if you want to see the other people in
your family though you could also just
like set up a [__] town to go to
Magic Mountain would then not have your
and not have your mom go or just invite
him to your place for no reason you
probably or any Six Flags could be great
adventure but like you you definitely
yeah don't that's okay don't feel bad
for not wanting to be around your mom I
I feel like maybe you want to go back
and see everybody but don't obviously
don't stay with your mom stay with
someone else and hang out with them
mostly and if you have to see your mom I
I just you know and she asks you
questions be [__] honest dude yeah
[__] yeah you know you're not that
old she's not that old so just you know
you still got time left if she wants to
do some self-reflection amazing
but like yeah that's so bad that's so
annoying and then if she did push back
and be like well why don't you you know
just be like oh because you were abusive
my whole life because you did this write
down stuff and just hand it to her
that'd be great like I already thought
about it and then it would [__] shut
her up you got a lot of anger there
buddy several pieces of paper though
like yeah she's asked the question you
give her one yeah she says
I have like 85 text messages so every
time she says why are you and then she
just hears a thing yeah in front of her
though just beat me yeah you beat me
that one time on that one Chris ding you
verbally abused me that one time on this
thing Thanksgiving
yeah cool okay
sounds great
what's up Delia Brothers yes and Alex
from New York it's about um I'm calling
because I have a bachelor's of Science
in music
been probably four years since I got my
degree but it's tough to get a job yeah
um and this industry I guess uh any
advice any um suggestions let me know
thank you I have a question did he say
music or business
I'm from Dallas and New York music
that's what he said a job for music
music so what
I mean dude that is such a s here's it's
done music's done AI you're done it's
done go get a [__] beat work for UPS
okay that is not exactly right UPS is
done too certainly not yet UPS is done
before music is done yep because people
don't get UPS job I mean our the Arts
are ostensibly about connection people
are not going to be replaced when it
comes to the actual music we listen to
not entirely no but I think that music
is going to get a really tough hard hit
right but it's already had a hard here's
the thing they're gonna make a new guys
AI That's a [__] artist and
everyone's gonna be like [__] yeah dude
and that's gonna be the number one
selling artist in the next 10 years and
it's not gonna be a real person mark my
words and they're gonna go to concerts
and they're gonna have [__] Graphics
of this person and Asians are gonna love
it by the way who gives a [__] that's
even if that's true which it isn't
that's one act that's not it doesn't
affect this guy man what happens when
there's another one and then what
happens when they do a duet with another
person and another one and then they
bring Tony Bennett back and then you
know what I mean then there's a Tony
Bennett concert and then people are just
watching the dead people that they
wanted to watch the whole time I'm just
saying I'll go see Tupac before I go see
Lil Durk that's all I'm saying okay
anyway
point is music's bit I mean the movie
business is is in serious trouble but
the music industry has been in serious
trouble since Napster yeah true music is
a hard business to Peg right now because
it's been in flux for so long and its
feet aren't even under it now like Tick
Tock came along and did it again it was
a sledgehammer to the entire industry
Sledge
hammer having a seizure seizure
wow I'm a sled
having seizure you know that [__] and
putting a mask on
I remember that [__] that's a great
music video oh I loved it
um
doesn't know how to eat
uh uh dude I don't even know how do you
give it
I think so yeah what was the question
does he have any do we have any advice
for him to get a job
that guy
that guy I don't do music man you're
[__] they got the Beatles songs better
than the Beatles they got the Drake AI
[__] with uh the weekend I'd rather
[__] I'd rather listen to that than
any other Drake song or the weekend song
I mean okay
the second they started make Peter
Gabriel AI songs I'm in dude I'm done
okay so
the advice would be AIP or Gabriel get
another job dude not not Kiss music
goodbye but like work at Creighton
you want to not have to be anxious
all the time about trying to get a job
in music get a job that can just
pay the bills every month and I don't
know if you want to be a musician or
just work in the industry but like
just like anything else in the Arts you
just gotta like hustle in every possible
way that appears in front of you you got
to create opportunities that are not
there you're not only like really really
really hustle I suggest it's always been
true now it's more true than ever I
suggest do the only job that will
survive the revolution of AI there's
only one job that will survive it
magician
and you gotta learn tricks because I'll
tell you what that's the only job that's
going to survive here's the comedian
will be the last one to go and the
magician will never go because nobody
gives a [__] if a robot can trick you
because robots have all sorts of Tricks
but a person
I was at that watching David Copperfield
and he goes like this go like this and
then he goes like this go like this and
he wound up like this and I don't know
how he did it but everyone was like what
the how do we how do we dude if a robot
did that you'd just be like it would
just be like
you know what I mean and then we'd be
like well that's just a robot David
copfield did it that's amazing here's my
money that's the only profession that
will survive the AI takeover is here's
the problem though so become a magician
if everybody takes your advice the
Market's gonna be oversaturated with
musicians and that sounds like actual
not musicians magicians what did I say
you just have to change like two letters
in your job no man I don't know man
that's that's that is
that
is a stumper
because it's like the music industry is
so [__] up right now yep of course you
can't get a job yeah like went into a
extremely hard
uh industry anyway like musicians like
at any point yeah getting a degree in
music is like getting a degree in film
or yeah it's a very unlike [__] hard
yeah God plays the ah it plays the knot
doesn't play the odds you know and it's
like the thing about the Arts in general
music movies Fine Art literature
whatever you're like
there isn't unlike business or medical
school or something that has a very
clear path toward a sustainable job for
the rest of your life doctor that
doesn't happen in the Arts that's not a
thing you know it's like when somebody
asks you how do I make it in movies how
do I make it in music it's like nobody
even knows dude even successful people
in those Industries don't know because
if you did what they did it wouldn't
work everybody has to ask me how I made
it the way to make it is to is to make
it how to tell the story about how you
made it there's no other way ask me how
I made in comedy how'd you make it in
comedy crushing
okay go ahead ask me again imagine again
yeah everybody heard you yeah but I have
another way to say it okay how did you
make any comedy shutting it down
okay yep any other go ahead yeah go
ahead oh how'd you make any comedy I
shake the room oh okay okay
there we go uh that's how I made it cool
and I keep shaking the room whatever
room I go into consider it shook okay
a tectonic plate
an earthquake interviewing an earthquake
dude I I yeah dude I shake the room so
there you go okay great so Chris shakes
the room and I don't know about I don't
know about the music industry I don't
say quit if you love it do it but damn
that's it that is hard hey put down a
glue the silverware to the [__] [__]
hey hey nail down nail down the the the
um the frame the pictures my mama of
Crystal Lee is coming in
hey dude
get the crazy glue out he's about to
shake the Room put that put it put your
Good China down on the ground already
that's what I'm just saying okay yeah
they do that at comedy clubs well they
don't have good China there but yeah
exactly hey sit down everybody everyone
said I know you want to stand but sit
down everyone's already sitting down
okay cool
we got another one
what's up Chris I'm Matt big fan uh I'm
in America and I'm dating a girl from
the UK and she's getting ready to move
here she has kind of a strained
relationship with her dad I don't know
all the details but I know it's not been
uh the best of times between the two of
them and we both recently just learned
that her dad took her ex and stepmom and
brother all out to dinner together so
they have like a family dinner without
her
and um she's wondering and by proxy me
if that's grounds for coming
cutting them out of their life or you
know what she should do so any advice
would be helpful there oh Chris do I
have this right he said her dad took her
ex
and the rest of her family her family
out to dinner
yes
or EX
and not him
no no I don't understand not him I don't
know him in the situation can you tell
me he's talking about his ex yeah his
current girlfriend yeah yeah she's
English and they have a strained
relationship yeah
her with her dad yeah she found out that
he her dad took her ex
and the rest of their family out to
dinner yeah without
even alerting her to the fact that that
was gonna happen I mean it all depends
on how
bad she he said it's bad already no no
but no I know but I'm saying how bad the
situation is with her and her ex but
that's just weird
that more than anything else that is
extremely strange yeah yeah if you have
a strained relationship as it is with
your dad why would your dad not go out
of his way to make it less strained yeah
and well and clear any potential because
it's strange because he's a deck problem
clearly it seems like it yeah so if
you're asking about the grounds I
wouldn't say that alone is grounds but
if it seems like it is this you know
breaking the camel's back scenario
grounds for what
I understand but I cutting him out of
her life yeah she's saying she wants to
cut him out of her life that's no that's
his question is that is this grounds for
that Bob I would say by itself no but
it's clearly one of many incidents that
this father has either made his daughter
uncomfortable or outright offended her
or whatever and yeah if it's of a piece
of an entire lifetime full of this [__]
then like yeah it's grounds because it's
just another offense and at a certain
point it's like
what the thing is that breaks
the bow or whatever it's like it doesn't
matter what that is it's just sometimes
it's a small thing but it's just there's
a everyone has a threshold yeah and if
this is the thing that crossed that
threshold then yeah she has grounds to
do what what imagine dad going to dinner
with
imagine mom going to dinner with like
one of your exes can you imagine that
and you
that's the scenario
and me yeah and her other siblings went
oh yeah yeah so it's not just that that
alone would be weird but what the [__]
were the other siblings doing I asked
them first ask them first what the [__]
is going on why did you go what is the
deal yeah right like why did you not
tell me and how was the temperature
because I got to talk to Dad because
this is so weird right that's that's the
first thing yeah
but assuming that maybe already happened
and you haven't gotten any answers which
now that is just odd dude I can't even
imagine a scenario where one of my
parents would do that well I mean yeah
like if you're friends with your ex and
they still do it and then and they hang
out and they're part of the family then
okay but if they're not and you have a
strange relationship with your dad
that's so [__] that's so weird dude
right I say get
yeah God a lot of a lot of family [__]
huh a lot of parents I mean everybody's
got so much family [__] all the time not
stop oh no I hope Calvin and Billy are
okay
hope they love me
they they love you I know right now now
yeah right now who knows who knows if
they won't no they fall out of love you
would love me okay yeah well that's good
um that's uh sad that's a sad one
I'm sad
I'm sad thanks for making me sad callers
people their stories life is hard you
know I want to make a bet about Barbie
oh wow bringing it back to Barbie I love
more sad trying to make me more the guy
loves Barbie okay go ahead well so
I mean I don't know what the BET should
be but
Chris is saying is going to have such a
steep drop-off if it if it does if it
performs better than x then that should
be the BET okay so I think it should be
so what should the BET be and then we
can sign off what Define your claim that
it will fall off like what and what to
what degree so worldwide it did what 155
I don't know I know worldwide I think
more now I think it's just that's just
America I think yeah
pretty sure we can look it up look it up
um okay
dude June's ears just popping out
yeah find the thing worldwide it made
382 there you go okay so much money so
what does it have to make to we don't
they never disclose what the advertising
[__] is they rarely do that I mean for
good reason so we can't make the bet but
it'll bomb
so Define what it probably needs to make
800 million dollars
it won't
okay actually I don't know if that's
already to date or if that was just the
weekend that's to date what is
that's today 380 something million two
days yeah because it was because it was
like 350 or something this right here
says it has topped 470 million globally
no so it's not today it didn't it didn't
this was posted three hours ago no it
didn't do that Chris says it didn't do
that yeah you can't believe this [__]
anyway Chris says no I'm a conspiracy
theorist also well [__] the BET then
yeah yep yep and Anthony also uh was in
a empty theater we saw it
that's true dude I mean I saw the
theater you were in Anthony yeah as a
matter of fact when did you go what what
time was the movie 11 A.M all right
11 A.M
he sent the picture at 10 56 a.m dude
wow dude what a liar wow what a liar
well that's pretty good four minutes
before the movie started was empty good
job Chris the guy's trying to say when
early dude he went early but he took the
picture late right wow he said it was
packed he lied we have a liar on our
team you lied I'll call my fiance right
now oh well she's already up to the game
dude yeah you already told her look you
said the pig I'm gonna call you around
yup this time if Chris gets wind and and
it's gonna when I call you at this time
it's gonna be about that if it checks
the time stamp yeah then you know what
sweetie doll she literally has the
script printed out in front of her that
he gave to her
gave her the directions about what was
going to happen and so well Chris yeah
and Matt yeah exactly it was packed yeah
right yeah and there wasn't a seat open
yeah
the the crowd rushed in at 10 58. yeah
you know what's funny what oh
a lot of people really did come in like
as the trailers
[Music]
this guy's a liar oh dude we have a liar
in our employees unbelievable if you've
got a [__] huge liar you know what's
funny you know it's just actually
absolutely hilarious what's that is that
a lot of people just did come during the
previews
unreal dude
well I mean it's neither here nor there
because Barbie made an obscene amount of
money whether that screening was sold
out or not all right let's do it leave a
comment please we love you I'm gonna be
in uh North Carolina and also Nashville
and Orange County chrisley.com
there we go leave a comment mattelia.com
for one-on-one sessions
if you want to sign up for the lifeline
luxury go to patreon.com Lifeline luxury
that's right and if you want the merch
go to lifelinemerch.com get every piece
or you hate us if you get every piece
you love us then I love you back yep
here you go
foreign
[Music]